[Applaudissements]
bonjour à toutes et à tous je voudrais
vous parler de la pluie
vous est il déjà arrivé d'être au beau
milieu d'une randonnée et vous fait
surprendre par la pluie alors vous êtes
loin de tout abri est alors parti pour
durer
donc il va falloir continuer au début on
lutte
intérieurement contre la pluie on rentre
la tête dans les épaules on râle à
chaque fois qu'une goutte ne tombe dans
la nuque
on veut même essayé la méthode coué il
ne pleut pas il ne pleut pas il ne pleut
pas et puis au bout d'un certain temps
on finit par s'habituer et là on peut
recommencer à regarder le paysage autour
de soi à voir comment la lumière a
changé à sentir l'odeur forte de l'herbe
mouillée
on peut même recommencer à discuter avec
ses camarades de marche sauter dans les
flaques pour les éclabousser et
finalement qu'est ce qui a changé par
rapport à la situation précédente
on a juste accepté le fait qu'on allait
être mouillé est ce que je voudrais vous
montrer c'est que le changement
climatique
ben c'est un petit peu comme cette pluie
et donc concernant cet orage qui nous
arrive dessus quelques constats qui ont
été des électrochocs pour moi l'idée ce
n'est pas du tout de vous faire peur
c'est juste qu'on soit d'accord sur ce
dont parle la terre c'est déjà réchauffé
de plus d'un degré depuis l'ère
préindustrielle et les scientifiques
disent qu'on s'oriente vers plus de a +
7 degrés d'ici la fin du siècle
sauf que + 2 degrés qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu'en france en
2050 toutes les personnes qui habitent
en ville doivent dormir sous des
moustiquaires pour éviter la propagation
des maladies tropicales
la dernière fois que j'ai dormi sous une
moustiquaire
je me suis réveillé avec une énorme
araignée à 5 centimètres du visage
je peux vous dire que j'ai vécu trois
secondes d'angoissé intense à me
demander cette araignée elle et en
dehors où les dents que la moustiquaire
alors à +5 degrés c'est plus chaud à +5
degrés trois personnes sur quatre vivent
actuellement dans des endroits où il ne
sera plus possible de vivre en 2100
trois personnes sur quatre
donc on aurait plutôt envie de
s'orienter vers l'option la plus
optimiste qu'on est actuellement que
sont les plus de degrés mais ça a l'air
pas si facile que ça à attendre
j'ai un ami qui vit avec une empreinte
carbone compatibles avec cet objectif
et concrètement ça veut dire qu'il ne
veut plus prendre l'avion qu'il ne prend
quasiment pas la voiture qu'ils mangent
uniquement bio local et de saison et
surtout il ne veut plus acheter ni
d'électronique ni de vêtements neufs je
vous laisse imaginer la galère pour les
sous-vêtements et la dernière chose à
faire c'est d'inciter l'état à prendre
des mesures concrètes
parce que nos actions individuelles
elles sont nécessaires mais elles ne
sont pas suffisantes et il ya des choses
sur lesquelles on n'a pas la main le
problème c'est qu'actuellement l'état il
attend que ce soit plutôt les
entreprises qui commencent à réduire les
émissions et les entreprises n'attendent
que ce soit les consommateurs qu'ils
soient prêts à mettre le prix pour des
produits plus responsables et les
consommateurs ils attendent que ce soit
les gros pollueurs et l'état qui
s'empare du sujet donc finalement tout
le monde se refile la patate chaude et
personne n'ose être le premier à prendre
le risque de diminuer son niveau de
confort ou son profit alors que la
concurrence continue de remettre le
problème à plus tard
moi c'est quelque chose que je constate
dans ma vie de tous les jours je
m'appelle fanny des gens je serai
diplômés de lisa est super héros en
décembre et mon travail c'est
d'accompagner les entreprises dans la
réduction de leur empreinte carbone et
pas plus tard que la semaine dernière
j'étais avec un client qui a décidé de
mettre en place une stratégie pour que
l'ensemble de son parc immobilier soit
aligné avec les 2 degrés est la question
qu ils nous posent c'est moi je veux je
veux m'engager en faveur du climat
mais vous avez pas quelques arguments
pour dire que ça va pas impacter le
résultat financier
alors nous on leur répond alors parlant
d' actifs échoué de risque de transition
et sa valeur de les rassurer
mais la vérité c'est qu'on n'y arrivera
pas sans mettre de l'argent sur la table
et auparavant moi ce genre de constat ça
me mettait dans une posture de
découragement et de frustration j'avais
l'impression que les enjeux étaient trop
vaste que le monde était devenu trop
compliqué tout est interconnecté
à chaque fois qu'on propose une solution
elle est critiquée parce que elle est
trop chère ou parce que elle et pas
juste socialement et je me sentais
complètement découragé alors j'ai besoin
d'identifier une porte d'entrée
quelque chose qui me semble est
prioritaire et sur lequel je pouvais
m'engager pour commencer à agir en
faveur du climat
et c'est comme ça que j'ai suivi une
formation de deux mois sur les enjeux de
la transition écologique et sociale qui
m'a donné quelques clés de lecture et
m'a permis d'y voir plus clair
actuellement on vit dans des sociétés
avec un très bon niveau de vie mais qui
respecte pas du tout les limites de la
planète
à côté de ça il ya des sociétés qui
vivent en total respect avec
l'environnement mais qui ont un moins
bon niveau de vie donc espérance de vie
plus faible plus courtes et des
conditions de vie plus sommaires je vous
laisse imaginer
dans le cas du réchauffement à +5 degrés
qui sont les trois personnes sur quatre
concernés mais on peut se poser la
question est ce que c'est possible de
combiner à la fois un bon niveau de vie
et respect de l'environnement
pour la petite histoire il ya une
société qui est à peu près pas revenue
et c'est cuba jusqu'à l'ouverture de ses
frontières
sauf que cuba c'était une dictature
donc ça pose une question supplémentaire
qui est celle des droits et des libertés
humaines
cette nécessité finalement de faire des
compromis m'amène à vous présenter un
outil développé par le chercheur en
anthropologie fabrice gagnant en 2017
qui reprend le triangle que vous
connaissez peut-être qui dit qu'on ne
peut pas avoir une solution qui soit à
la fois qu'on évite bien et pas cher
comment s'applique aux sociétés humaines
on peut pas concilier beaucoup
d'écologie de liberté et de complicité
pour illustrer sa avec un exemple
concret
si on reprend cuba c'était une société
relativement complexe avec un certain
degré dit d'écologie et par contre pas
du tout liberté donc où la situer
quelque part par là si on prend une
société du paléolithique aucun degré de
complexité assez libre assez écologique
on l'assuré quelque part par là
maintenant notre société actuelle
moi je la trouve personnellement très
complexe avec encore un certain degré de
liberté
par contre niveau écologie on repassera
donc je la situe quelque part par là
d'un triangle
est ce qu'on voit c'est pour se
rapprocher d'un des trois facteurs ça se
fait forcément au détriment de 1 voire
des deux autres et c'est pour ça que
pour moi cet outil il nous permet de
faire le deuil de nos illusions de
l'illusion d'une société parfaite honoré
à la fois les 3 et si on observe les
solutions qui nous sont proposés par
cette société pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques
c'est le même problème la première
solution à laquelle on pense c'est la
technologie parce que je sais pas si
vous êtes au courant vous les ingénieurs
mais on attend de vous que vous sauviez
le monde sans pression le problème de la
technologie c'est que ça demande
beaucoup d'énergie
est ce que vous savez à quel moment dans
l'histoire de l'humanité on a commencé à
réduire notre consommation de charbon
la réponse c'est jamais on n'a jamais
assisté à une transition énergétique
on a toujours assisté à une accumulation
énergétique
quand on a commencé à exploiter à
exploiter le nucléaire ou les énergies
renouvelables ces sources d'énergie sont
venus s'ajouter à la somme d'énergie
qu'on consomme et c'est sur ça qui est
basé notre croissance économique
la deuxième solution qu'on nous propose
c'est le pic pétrolier on arrêtera de
polluer il y aura plus de ressources
sauf que si on consomme l'intégralité
des ressources pétrolières connues
actuellement ça nous amène déjà à +4 ou
+5 degrés pour moi ces solutions
c'est un petit peu des solutions qui
attendent qu'un coup de baguette magique
viennent de sauver sans qu'on ait besoin
de faire d'effort ou de changer nos
modes de vie c'est un peu comme cette
idée que les biocarburants vont
permettre de décarbonés l'aéronautique
est ce que vous savez que pour
approvisionner une seule compagnie
aérienne
il faudrait la superficie d'un pays d'un
pays comme la pologne
vous y croyez vraiment vous
moi je vous propose de commencer à
réfléchir à des solutions qui soient
réalistes et pour ça je vais vous
demander de fermer les yeux tous et
d'imaginer une société dans laquelle
vous aimeriez vivre et maintenant je
vais vous demander de la placer sur ce
triangle dans quelle zone elle se
situerait votre société
moi j'ai fait l'exercice et vous l'aurez
peut-être compris je suis ce qu'on
appelle une babos écolo ou une hippie
pour les plus anciens et je fais le
choix de renoncer à un certain degré de
complexité au profit de plus d'écologie
et de liberté donc ma société idéale se
situerait quelque part par là là
et je dis pas que la technologie c'est
forcément quelque chose de mauvais
seulement pour moi on utilise trop
souvent à des fins inutiles comme de
mettre la climatisation à 18 degrés
l'été et le chauffage à 25 degrés
l'hiver ou alors de commander un livre
sur internet et se faire livrer alors
qu'on peut aller dans la librairie du
coin discuter avec la libraire et
profiter de ses conseils
ce qui est intéressant aussi dans le
fait de se projeter dans une société
c'est que derrière ça nous donne un peu
un cap une vision de ce vers quoi on
veut aller et moi dans ma vie de tous
les jours je peux vérifier que mes choix
et mes actions sont alignés avec ses
convictions
avec le changement que je voie
européenne et c'est pour ça que si je
dis de prendre la voiture ou de
commander un beurre je fais 15 ou 30
minutes de vélo sur la pluie c'est pas
quelque chose que je subis c'est quelque
chose que je choisis je peux pas me
plaindre parce que je sais pourquoi je
le fais je le fais parce que j'ai envie
de me battre pour limiter le
réchauffement à +2° je le fais pour
qu'on continue d'avoir des saisons pour
que le père noël finissent pas en
maillot de bain comme en australie et je
le fais pour que toutes les personnes
sur cette planète et accès aux
conditions de vie les plus de descentes
possible
il ya un an j'avais fait la liste des
choses que je voulais faire de ma vie et
ce vers lui après avoir suivi cette
formation et j'ai lu aller visiter
istanbul le alors je me suis dit sans
prendre l'avion
ça va être compliqué mais j'ai une
collègue qui allaient à istanbul lui et
à vélo et je pense qu'elle a pris le
temps de profiter du trajet et qu'en
arrivant devant fin de sophie elle
apparaît juste pris une photo avant de
passer à la traction suivante les
changements climatiques
c'est une menace c'est une menace
certaine mais quelque part c'est
peut-être aussi une opportunité celle de
redécouvrir le plaisir que c'est de
prendre son temps de profiter des choses
de ralentir c'est aussi un incroyable
challenge intellectuel
on n'a jamais eu de problèmes plus
complexes à résoudre et on n'y arrivera
pas seulement avec des équations on est
obligé de prendre en compte des sciences
humaines tels que l'économie la
politique la psychologie ou la
sociologie et ça pour moi ça a été une
formidable découverte parce que ça m'a
permis de remettre de l'humain dans mon
métier d'ingénieur et je suis également
persuadé que l'art a un rôle assez
important à jouer parce qu'ils vous
permettent de créer de nouveaux
imaginaires et de changer les normes
sociales
actuellement la norme c'est de manger de
la viande deux fois par jour de posséder
une voiture même si on habite en ville
et l'art peut nous permettre de changer
ça et peut-être aussi de sortir de
l'idée de l'écologie comme quelque chose
de de punitif et de donneur de leçons
parce que moi je trouve que les écolos
actuellement c'est un peu comme cette
personne dans les films d'horreur qui
dit n'allez surtout pas par là et tout
le monde y va quand même
sur la liste de mes envies j'ai enlevé
certaines choses mais j'en ai aussi
rajouter et c'est comme ça que j'ai posé
mes seul jour de congé pendant mon stage
pour aller faire les vendanges et tout
le monde me disais mais tu tu prends des
vacances pour aller travailler
sauf que moi qu'est ce qui me pèse dans
mon métier tous les jours c'est d'être
assise derrière un ordinateur ne pas
avoir le temps de me dépenser
physiquement et pendant les vendanges
j'étais dehors toute la journée j'ai
discuté avec des gens qui venaient de
plans de milieux sociaux différents qui
avait beaucoup de choses à partager et
je faisais quelque chose d'utile et de
concret avec mes mains j'ai décidé que
prochainement je passerais à mi temps et
le reste de mon temps je me consacrerai
à une activité manuelle et concrète et
avant je répare envisager ce genre de
choses parce que j'avais peur de la
réaction mon entourage peur de gagner
moins d'argent peur de sortir de ma zone
de confort et je me suis posé la
question
ok qu'est ce qui peut se passer dans le
pire des cas et je me suis rendu compte
qu'en fait je risquais pas grand chose
est par contre en n'osant pas suivre ses
envies je m'assurer de me décevoir moi
même et ça je trouve que c'est beaucoup
plus grave
ce que j'aurais aimé qu'on me dise il ya
trois ans c'est au vu des enjeux actuels
je peux pas continuer de tout vouloir
donc il faut que je me demande qu'est ce
qui est vraiment important pour moi et
que j'ai le courage de faire les choix
en conséquence parce que j'ai réalisé
qu'aujourd'hui c'est en ne changeant
rien qu'on prend le plus grand risque
tiens je crois que je sens les premières
gouttes arrivée qui vient se baladait
d'ailleurs avec moi merci